our series our more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us as
schools and child care centers close to
slow the spread of the corona virus many
doctors and nurses and health care
workers are scrambling for basic child
care Errol Barnett shows us how
volunteers are stepping up to help we
cannot wait until the pandemic is in our
schools when Minnesota announced
statewide school closures surgical
resident Ariela Altman felt panicked but
thankfully babysitter's and I emailed
and filled out the form right away and
within another 24 to 48 hours they said
it had matched us with these medical
students Minnesota covitz it''s was
founded by volunteer medical students to
help healthcare workers balance life
with ever more essential jobs it's
incredibly important to me to give back
to the people that teach us every single
day as students attending physicians are
being strapped at their highest capacity
- yet they don't have a childcare for
their children
organizers like London Robinson work
remotely grouping hundreds of volunteers
into pods to minimize risk then assign
each part to a single healthcare worker
from cafeteria employees to physicians
really need every single person that we
can on the front lines right now a third
full capacity one study estimates more
than two million children of health care
workers may need care as the pandemic
worsens as more parents need child care
more students are stepping up to health
so that's very exciting high school
junior Rio Pittock and her older sister
Hannah also see that growing need a lot
of nurses especially we've had people
say you know they're working you know
alternating shifts with their spouse
each 12 hours and they you know really
need someone the Pittock launch step up
to sit after Hannah's senior year of
college was cut short by the pandemic
their program also pairs homebound
students with stressed-out parents it's
one babysitter for one family our
primary goal here was to keep health
care workers up and running a secondary
goal was really to give our generation
of class
to step up Mayo Clinic pharmacist Sarah
and John Lee Young say step up services
have been invaluable in protecting their
daughter Eloise there's a lot of anxiety
about what's gonna happen the next day
or the next week or the next month given
that I'm still in the hospital setting
you know some of that would be if Eloise
were to somehow contract the virus
knowing what the next next steps are has
put my mind at ease a bit while these
groups grew quickly there is a sense
they've not yet met demand and still
need more help the need was
instantaneous and it was overwhelming
and it still is overwhelming in a
university student that has had a
background check immunizations or CPR
first aid training we would love to take
you on please tell everyone that it's
very easy to set up and it will make a
difference in people's communities we
made it so that it's an easy platform to
replicate for anywhere in the country
CBS this morning
Errol Barnett New York step-up just said
it's one of those things where every
little bit helps if you can help anybody
that those are the people you need to
help the healthcare workers yeah
absolutely you got to stay busy at this
time as well yes yes